[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant on va manger des trucs tu
penses que tu devrais mettre le nez un
petit peu je te demande et ça commence
comment ça va ça va juste sur un petit
billet sur l'euro millions alors non par
s'étaient vantés après cyril vous savez
chaque semaine depuis quelques semaines
je commence cette chronique avec un
dossier pions et le dossier que lui
regarde tout ce qui se passe pour nous
et les coulisses pendant les pubs
pendant tout ça et bien entendu ils
voient des choses qui ne doit pas voir
exactement mais ça je l' ai vu ce qui va
suivre
et oui vous allez voir ce qui s'est
passé baba j'ai un dossier sur baba à
l'international oui peut être les
derniers
baba était à barcelone et à barcelone
baba était très agitée mais en six
[Musique]
beau gosse mais voulait garder pas pour
les grandes ferias à ces jeux vous
inquiétez pas il ya assez de la semaine
prochaine
il y en aura encore un très joli hâle et
sert il savait que les chroniqueurs ne
travaille pas l'émission ça je sais vous
savez plus où regarder c'est pour ça ils
sont de plus en plus parce qu'ils font
tellement rien non là la nouvelle équipe
travaillera ainsi si franchement
guillaume genton travaille beaucoup
nicolas pernikoff travaille beaucoup
bernard montiel travaille beaucoup
tiffany travaille beaucoup mais ça ne
soit pas et isabelle franchement elle
dort très peu non et c'est important
d'avoir un lieu où faire la sieste c'est
important vous devriez serrer la vis
cyril parce que parfois il se balade
dans l'est dans les loges joie ils vont
devoir fonds vert et ils se disent bon
bah je vais vaincre husté dans plusieurs
émissions regardées
j'ai les images même si c'est assez
compliqué quand même
quelle plante de la famille des éric
assez odorantes est couché on continue
quel champignons printanier comestibles
norme ce gag direction compiègne maca
rendez vous à l'aise comme avec kevin
elle des chimistes irina bactériologiste
et guillaume de nay microbiologiste
[Musique]
salut l'uda des le mec de millas trop
high aulas lui bien eux les gars ja
lemay camilla bien le mec habile à la
fff m mais quoi encore encore une
antienne mais place à la cote hdd jeudi
c'est seulement samedi ça va péter
bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver dans votre émission gym direct
aujourd'hui on fait du stretching et je
ne suis pas seul je vous accompagne et
de bonnets salut bonnet et on commence
tout de suite c'est parti allez on ouvre
les gens
[Musique]
rdg souffrir
à
comment vous appelez-vous je m'appelle
lisa et bien je crois que la scène
entière est à vous france inter
première radio de france au hockey
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on a d'autres choses à l'est puisque
c'est notre indique de la rédaction
on continue avec une pastille découverte
la semaine dernière que toute la planète
people a réclamé à l'os et le 50
secondes inside tpm pea rebelles alors
ça on adore
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans 50
secondes inside de pmp et au sommaire ce
soir tiffany et remo qui pendant les
pubs de tpm paix pour les cours de
sciences naturelles
[Rires]
il sera très connu
[Applaudissements]
visiblement l'anatomie de raymond est
impressionnante
et puis en exclusivité dans 50 secondes
inside qu'élever novelli un énorme ce
coup c'est super car cabaye toujours
très sympa avec ses vieux amis
[Musique]
elvis
je suis sain
et puis ne manquez pas prochainement
isabelle morini-bosc guest star de la
grosse rigolade c'est la jeune femme qui
va à la pharmacie dit bonjour je
voudrais me compresse qu'il ya un an et
eefje dépenses christus et puis en
parlant d' humour nicolas pernikoff est
lui aussi prêt pour la grosse rigolade
c'est un grand sensible jean renard il
faut le savoir vraiment si je comprends
que ça des penne voilà maintenant c est
ce qu on prouve sa des penne voilà
maintenant c est au fini avec bernard
montiel visiblement les uv lui ont donné
chaud très chaud à tiffany ltd
et ça c'est vrai c'est vu ouvrir
c'est du vrai jour
et quel événement aussi la catastrophe
une dernière chose
win dernière si lille je trouve très
beau ce soir c'est ça mais aussi très
talentueux et il faut le dire cette
semaine avec près d'un million deux cent
mille téléspectateurs
vous êtes un record saison va corser à
tous merci si les téléspectateurs merci
à vous également versée merci à vous les
cherry et vous voulez je vous le dise
oui vous l'avez pas volé ce record
pourquoi parce qu'il ya eu du très grand
baba cette semaine à la marque n'a pas
que merkel n'a pas de culotte
alors isabelle morini-bosc qu'on nous
l'expliquent le nutritionniste jean
michel cohen au micro de tpm p jean
michel cohen
c'est le seul du tri sur liste qui 3 kg
par jour je vous demande juste un
service les chéris s'il vous plaît
est-ce qu'il y en a qui peuvent se
dévouer pour parler isabelle pendant la
plume
pour bagad sant dont il veut pas fermer
sa gueule
il avait jeté un beauf - ce soir c'est
un jeu c'est comme un hypocrite on sûr
qu'ils vont bouffer d'exploser mais
amiens rigole avec des amis jouent à
bouffe ma nuque englouti un max de h'cup
pour gagner un jeu basse émission
sérieuse ici sur se battre